good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Monday hope everybody has
had an amazing weekend who hope
everyone's doing fine whoa I'm not going
in that Lake hi luro happy Monday happy
last week of work before vacation yes
you guys enjoy these episodes Savor them
make them laugh fifth to final fifth to
last we've got five more before the end
of the year and I am gonna miss everyone
desperately but I am so depressed like
it's not normal
that and and being depressed and like
sad really goes against every fiber of
who I am like my natural inclination is
just to be like funny and happy and not
being able to do that like and just
honestly this feels so forced and I'm
glad I'm glad I have to do the show
every day because it does force me to
like be happy for an hour but it's just
so the antithesis of how I'm really feel
feeling and that feeling is so unnatural
to me like I'm just not a sad person I
don't think I'm a person who's prone to
like depression knockwood you know bite
my tongue um that I don't know what to
do well we want you to be yourself on
the show however you're feeling like
don't feel like you have to force
anything I we all understand that you're
sad majorly and sad and we're here for
you but if I may yeah attempt to cheer
you up what do you have for me like we
have family vacation starting next week
and we are so excited we haven't taken a
proper vacation in forever like from the
show we've had like days off and stuff
but like a proper trip vacation good Let
the Good Times Roll not in so long so
for your mental state like you just need
to make it to next week and this is
going to be a really hard week but then
things are going to turn around and it's
going to be happy times the thing is is
like I just miss my Theo and I don't
know why he was taken away from me and
like the the the key to my happiness is
so simple like give me [__] Theo back
so she's reached the stage of anger no
I've reached the stage of this is
[__] stupid yeah bring back to #
bring back my boy yeah like what the
[__] I know it's it's it's wrong it's
wrong it's stupid it's moronic and it
makes no goddamn sense and I'm I'm a
logical person you know and this is
simply
illogical I do D
agree I like did everything in my power
to stay busy this weekend when I am busy
I am okay but being home and just laying
down which is my favorite thing to do
it's been taken from you it's been taken
because that's when I really really
spiral like I was so good yesterday I
was out of the house all day we woke up
and we went to Jersey we were at the
tailor we watched football we made lotas
we made chili we decorated the Christmas
tree like I was busy bus busy busy we
didn't get home I'm I'm sure they were
like when will these people leave my
house I didn't leave I did not want to
leave then I eventually had to go home
and the second I got to bed I was just
crying like I can't my bed has become a
sad place and that's really not cool cuz
my bed is my happy place I feel like
distracting yourself is so good because
you need to like find pockets of
happiness but I feel like you also need
to get your cries out and the more you
cry and the sooner you cry like the
sooner you'll start to reach the other
side so like pushing it off you can only
do that for so long
I know and then like I really thought
like drinking would help and it did cuz
on Friday night we went to Jingle Ball
and I was like whatever let's just
[__] go like me and Ben were like I
guess we don't have to get home in a
certain time to walk Theo so we're like
let's rage we just drank so much and we
really did have a good time at Jingle
Ball I didn't know One Republic was
playing like I really needed to prepare
myself cuz by the time they went on like
I was really drunk and when they sang I
lived like I was crying like I was
crying how even a sober non-g breathing
person will cry during that song they
were so good and we had so much fun and
we stayed out so late we went afterwards
for drinks the second I get into the cab
I'm crying I cried myself to sleep like
I cannot be alone and I think drinking
was not the right thing for me like I
didn't really drink the rest of the
weekend cuz I was like this is not I
thought it was a fix but it wasn't a fix
I was so emotional it's a Band-Aid but
it heightens your emotions that come
down even for a non-g grieving person is
hard yeah so that's kind of a
seesaw it wasn't the right move but even
though I did have like a lot of fun but
the second it was all over like I was
crying well here's a fun tidbit because
of your Jingle Ball um Excursion on
Friday Night Olivia and I have been
invited to Florida's y 100 Jingle Ball
oh my God you guys should go it was
really good is it the same lineup no so
we were talking this morning and I was
actually like that's kind of the perfect
thing for us to do like a little Mom's
Night Out concert a bunch of different
people we don't have to like commit to
one artist but then I looked at who's
playing the Florida one and like we are
too old who is it no like I don't even
know if you would go not because it's
you know y 100 thank you for the
invitation um I'll show just excuse a
little younger demographically
marshmallow oh
AJR even though they have that one song
that I like fny Taylor ster was like I
can't wait to see AJR I'm like who is
that no they have that one really good
song that's like it's that's what she
said wait let me just search what it is
you'll know it when I say the
title
bang I don't know oh yeah it was in the
Kardashian commercials anyway fla of
course because it's
Florida ludicrous okay Lonnie that's
would be the one artist I would go for I
love Lonnie Lanny I don't know David
Kushner sounds like a Jew Jew kie three
eyes and Paul
Russell yeah so I don't know if that's
worth leaving your children for the
night no it's not even about like the
leaving it's just like is that how I
want to it's going to be a lot of energy
and then like we are going away and I
need my energy to pack and and get from
place A to B and like is that where I
want to my think that's your journey
probably not but I just want to thank
iHeart radio for inviting us and you
know in another world we really would
have gone yeah um it was really good and
the thing is is I if it was the same
lineup I would tell you 100% to go
because I know Olivia is obsessed with
jelly roll well and he was really great
at first when she called me we thought
it was the same we assumed it was like
similar lineup I thought it was like a
traveling tour and then we were thinking
about it when we thought it was Bina
Carpenter Olivia Rodrigo share I was
like we'd have to stay up really late
for share and then no Jackie share was
like third oh she obviously wanted to go
home she's like let me sing my Christmas
song lipsync the [__] out of it and get
the hell out of here well then we hung
up and I was like let me check the
lineup cuz the our decision will be
lineup dependent and it was not the one
that you had whatsoever so that made our
decision easy but again like thank you
so much for the invitation next year for
sure it was really good let me say One
Republic was amazing and I'm so glad
that like these kids cuz it really it's
an event for children I'm glad these
kids are being educated on One Republic
like it was absolutely imperative that
they be there and demand respect from a
younger generation and the younger
generation respected it like they knew
apologize it was really cute
jelly roll was fabulous Sita Carpenter
was amazing I'm so obsessed with her and
then of course Olivia Rodrigo brought
the house down my husband was like not
okay it was really good I'm so glad I
went I'm glad you went too it looked
really fun perfect thing to do good
clean
fun but of course you know for every up
what goes up must come down and that's
what you're feeling and what's really
Dawning on me is like and I feel like
everybody I really don't want to cry
again I feel like everyone in the family
let it out everyone the whole world is
with you in Du like no one expects you
to be perky tury you know like and
everyone knows how much I hate being
alone and like whenever Ben like
literally leaves the house for a second
like I hate being alone it's like one of
my biggest fears and I forgot about that
feeling so much because I really wasn't
ever alone and now with Theo and now
like that feeling it's familiar to me
like that feeling of loneliness like
it's comes back and I just hate it like
I hate being alone and I forgot that
like the'll really fixed that yeah I
remember that so
I need to get another dog but I also
have like a lot of things coming up that
like I was feeling really guilty about
and I was going to say no to a bunch of
stuff in January because it's just like
a lot of time to be away from home um so
now I'm just going to everything so I I
I do want one now like literally today I
would go if somebody had one I would go
pick one up but I do think I should wait
until January's over just cuz like I
have a lot of trips and it's not nice to
like get a puppy and then take all these
trips where you going going to Mexico
I'm going to Dallas I'm going to
Miami Miami
yeah you're going to come see me of
course you didn't tell me I haven't
booked my trips yet but I have a wedding
it's February not January but like I'll
I'll probably like stay by you yeah yeah
we discussed February that there was a
date and then we're just like working it
cuz I also I'm going to do something
crazy in the next few months yeah you
are I'm going to go to
Disney and while it sounds so cute I
imagine it's probably for a parent like
the worst experience on the planet so I
feel like we've built it up to be the
worst but there are ways to go
especially if you live in Florida where
it doesn't have to be that terrible
where you can like drive up spend one
day at the park and then go home the
next day and that's not so torturous
especially like you have your your car
and I can pack everything that I need so
I am going to find the joy in it and I'm
excited for it but I remember you saying
cuz we've like talked about the dreaded
trip to Disney as a parent before you
even had kids and I remember remember
you saying and I thought it was so
profound at the time you're like I'm not
going to take my kids to Disney until
they'll be able to remember it for sure
and I was and I don't know if yeah the
kids will remember it no they won't and
I was wrong for that because even if
they don't remember it in what however
many years like for that one day they
will have the best day ever and that's
what's important okay and they would
they would love it like I I I would what
I should have said is I will not take
them until they can appreciate it and I
know now like they would appreciate it
so much even if they and they would
remember it for a little while but then
you know when they're grown they won't
remember but that's fine they don't need
to to yeah remember everything remember
their time at Disney yeah no and they're
going to love it so much like cayla's
going to freak out so it's good they're
going to lose their minds like they have
to go yeah no it's the right thing to do
I don't know we put like too much
emphasis on them remembering stuff and
it's like what about
we we you're the one who said it as a
society sorry okay okay what about just
one good day OGD like I'm down for one
good what about two like trying to make
every day as fun as possible just sure
that's enough for me DI I was FaceTiming
with Kayla and everyone's been so
helpful like the kids have been calling
me all weekend cuz they know like
they're literally all I have now how sad
is that and Kayla nobody knows but Kayla
was getting ready for bed me and Olivia
like read her a book and stuff it was
she was being so cute and she said Can
Theo sleep in bed with me and I said
Kayla Theo's dead you didn't say that no
I said oh no F
can't well even if he wasn't deceased he
couldn't saying that like Theo died the
d word yeah it's so not okay like now I
understand why people always say like he
crossed the Rainbow Bridge I used to be
like oh that's kind of cringe no no
because saying like Theo
the OED is is so not [__] okay you
know I was thinking about that this
morning that in all of everything that
happened last week like we've never said
the OED because he didn't and like when
I had to you know I told you guys I
alert just like he wasn't a d right
right he wasn't dog when I alerted his
dog walking crew I said you know Theo
left us like the past past d i e d uh
what no
my boy no and let me tell you the stage
of grief that I'm currently like dealing
with and Ben thinks I'm so crazy but
like I'm so paranoid like if if it's
true that like Theo is d e a d and he's
like in doggy heaven like I can make
peace with that but I have no proof that
he's there and now I'm like feeling like
because I didn't wait till the very end
of like the the putting down
euthanization process and that like you
know what if they pulled the needle out
and they thought he was cute and
somebody took him home and like made
them him their sex slave yeah no no
that's what that's what I'm I'm freaking
out like if Theo is in fact d e a d like
I can make peace with that but I feel
like he's not like CU I don't feel his
Spirit or anything and he hasn't like
come to me in a dream I and I'm I'm
waiting for Theo to come to me in a
dream and I know that I'm very dream I
I'm not like a woo woo but I really do
believe like people have passed on come
and visit you in dreams I think the
subconscious is very powerful and I had
that experience when we were younger I
had a very powerful dream about our dad
and ever since then I've really felt
peace I really have Theo hasn't come to
me yet Theo's still filling out his
paperwork at the Pearly Gates like he's
or or he's in someone's
[Laughter]
basement I just don't feel like Theo is
seriously not on this planet like in a
physical sense I really am so paranoid
that something happened to him like I
know it sound crazy because the for that
I have nothing that I can like say to
make you feel better it's possible says
I'm crazy stop
Ben says I'm
crazy it's just it's possible but I
would I just like if he wasn't here in a
physical sense like I would feel him
well no I think that like he until he's
like fully escon in heaven you're not
he's not going to come to you like I
said he's filling out his paperwork at
the fly at the ply Gates like getting
acquainted finding his room but then I
also like I didn't do the thing that I
guess some people do was very like you
get the remains back so I'll never know
no I mean even if they it could be sad
yeah agreed no I would say if we're
going to use our logical thinking caps
Theo was in a place where he was
uncontrollably [__] and vomiting
yeah would someone really want doesn't
make for a good sex slave does it make
for a good like anything yeah to bring
home that responsibility I feel like if
they were going to dog nap they would
pluck someone else off the street you
know maybe go down down the hall to the
daycare right right and take one of
those healthy dogs right and I keep just
like it's because this weekend it was so
beautiful and it was almost like I was
being taunted like the amount of dogs on
the street and I almost just wanted to
shake these people and be like what are
you doing what are you doing like give
your dog a kiss give your dog a scratch
do not take your dog's health for
granted like I want just shake them well
you can use your platform to remind
everyone
I feel like the toaster who have been
listening and been on this journey with
me and who are dog parents have are
definitely like learning from my
experience and just like giving their
dogs extra kisses and cuddles like I
know that I've that Theo is responsible
for thousands of kisses you know
thousand of hugs Theo did not D in
vain but it almost feels like he did cuz
like for what like why did you have to
go and kill Theo like really what was
the point
God
why
my eye twitch is back and bigger than
ever never stop asking why I
won't well Theo remained number one of
the comedy charts last week yeah his
legacy lives on his legacy lives on and
it will continue to do so no this is so
dumb like it's so dumb I'm so mad I'm so
mad I was mad so
mad
oh my God I haven't thought of that
reference in years memory unlocked How
does it go I was mad I was so mad so I
took the scissors and I heard him in the
back I stabed him in the back that's the
most iconic episode of lawn order SV
when that actual six-year-old like
killed someone at Catholic school with a
pair of scissors I was mad I was so mad
so I took the scissors and I stabbed him
in the back I heard him in the back I
love that episode I used to quote that
all the time you did that's swear I got
it from and the actress who who was
saying the monologue I just performed is
that little girl from Jersey girl who
then I think years later ended up on The
Voice I'm
unfamiliar oh she has I don't even know
if I ever saw the episode I just have
lived it with tury if you've lived with
me you don't need to see the episode
it's like it mine's better so true and
you know when you quote a monologue so
many times over so many years that the
monologue you like end up quot is
nothing like the original of course I
believe like if I were to actually watch
that episode of SVU I wouldn't even
recognize the moment that I'm trying to
reference because I changed it so much I
like added my own spin but I believe she
was from Staten Island and she had like
a really thick accent and she had like a
focked bob haircut because the boy who
she killed was bullying her and he cut
her hair so she then took the scissors
and sted him in the back and H him in
the back right that's like I recently
listen to the Dora the Explorer theme
song because we've Riff on it
Theodora and then we go no I can't even
enjoy that song now Claudia they're two
different songs I was like looking for
the theme song I was like the Explorer
crunchy Angel it's not that we like made
up beautiful chairman Dora we definitely
um sampled Dora but we did not copy Dora
that's disappointing to hear I know like
I wanted to listen to it on Spotify and
like the song doesn't exist I guess
we're going to have to record it we
really need to record toast
Tunes Theodora
theora
Theodora Angel Dora love King
Dora Dora aun he loves you Dora I'll
never forget you for the long as I live
Dora do strong
Dora I hate my life
Dora angel in heaven Dora or in
someone's basement sex slave Dora why is
happening to me life is so
unfair true
Dora don't [__] bring Brew into this
I said true oh oh my God true Dora like
cuz you said life was so unfair true oh
got it true like TR the truth I would
not have inserted Brew in that moment
you know I'm so I'm just like keeping
Brew out of sight I know and I'm kind of
like on a roller coaster of emotions
with Brew cuz I know you've been keeping
him out of sight but he ended up on our
FaceTime last night and he looks so much
like my baby and he's such a sweet boy
but I hate him and I don't want to see
him but he's like going through what
you're going through too like you guys
could be partners in this he's grieving
the loss of a beloved
Mentor no seriously [__]
Brew you don't [__] everyone [__]
everyone with a dog who's so happy okay
she doesn't mean it you guys no I do I
really do so as stated earlier in the
show it seems as though you've reached
the anger stage what are the five stages
I always need a refresher are there only
five the five stages of grief yeah shock
denial bargaining acceptance no no no oh
this is good denial maybe that's were
you there first no cuz I knew that this
was going to happen because I've been
like experiencing it for a few weeks
denial anger
bargaining
depression
acceptance and they have to go in that
order that is what this is article is
about understanding bement um you might
hear people say things like oh I've
moved on from denial and now I'm
entering the angry stage but I don't
think they always happen in order they
are nonlinear says K kuer Ross says
they're
nonlinear yeah I've definitely and I
bounce between all of them like at once
yeah
okay
you're like depression and anger
yeah this is [__]
like whatever let's move on let's move
on because I'm here it's my job to
distract law and put on a great jolly
good show for everyone so without
further ad do Ado here are the fast five
stories that you need to know and the
fast five stories that you need to know
are brought to you by DraftKings unwrap
the first of many presents this season
with holidays on the house from
DraftKings casino with hundreds of games
prizes and promos DraftKings Casino has
everything on your list right now new
players who play $5 get $100 instantly
in Casino credits what are you waiting
for cozy up with all the classics like
slots blackjack or roulette or play
exclusive games you'll only find at
DraftKings casino to feel the holiday
cheer all season long download the
DraftKings casino app now and sign up
with promo code the toast and play $5 to
get that $100 in Casino credits that's
promo code the toast the T O A St only
at DraftKings Casino the crown is yours
gambling problem call 1800 Gambler or
visit 1800 gambler. net in Connecticut
help is available for problem gambling
call 8887895118
wage you're required Max $100 in Casino
credit awarded which requires One X play
through within 7 Days terms at casino.
draftkings.com holidays onth house
restrictions apply today's episode is
also brought to you by roback roback
active wear it's safe to say that
everyone's talking about roback
especially because we can't stop talking
about how we're ordering clothes for our
trip and keep wearing them on the show
leading up to the actual trip and
ruining the clothes before we even get
to wear them and that's robach man they
have the cutest sets comfy sets for men
for women perfect for like a cozy trip
which is exactly what we're doing and
they just launched their brand new
jogger and Hoodie sets we cannot take
them off they're super soft so
comfortable and just perfect for the
fall they use their vsoft Fabric and the
name says it all it is the softest
fabric that we own whether you're
lounging around or having a casual day
out and about these jogger sets are for
you and the good news is that robach
also has you covered for the man in your
life whether it's their performance
hoodies polos or joggers it's all the
men we know we if you want your man
looking good then get him robach robach
is perfect sets I'm just I'm in my sets
era it's too hard to like come up with a
cute outfit and be creative and stylish
like who am I and a win tour no robach
gives you a full outfit I love a set
also for the man in your life it's hard
for men to like wear sweats and look put
together but robach has them covered and
with fall right around the corner make
sure to check out robach use code toast
on roback.com for a generous 20% off
your first order of any fall essential
that is spelled r h o b
a.com and the code is toast for 20% off
on everything for yourself and for the
man in your life so check them out now
that's code toast t s at robac RH o
bac.com 20% off with code toast today's
episode is also brought to you by kitch
gamechanging that's what Kit's big
biggest fans say about their time-saving
beauty Essentials for Hair Skin and Body
so are you ready to change your beauty
game whatever your budget your skin type
your hair type kit believes that you
deserve little indulgences at affordable
prices morning noon and night started in
2010 by selling hair ties door too kit
is a self-funded female founded and now
carried in over 20,000 retail locations
brand maybe you've seen their satin
pillowcases I've seen kitch all over Tik
Tok it's like what all the cool kids
wear um so I'm like an officially like
cool they have um satin pillowcases caps
eye masks all these products that are
great for your hair and skin while you
sleep or they have the heatless satin
curling rollers if you want to say
goodbye to heat damage but their latest
kit viral craze is the rice water
shampoo bars which can improve your
overall hair growth in density rice
water is like the thing right now for
hair growth reviewers say that they'll
never use a bottle of shampoo again and
that their hair feels and looks 1,000%
better between washes plus right now for
a limited time you can live the Barbie
dream life with the Barbie by kit
collection featuring Kit's best-selling
satin pillowcases in iconic Barbie pink
so right now kit is offering you 30% off
your entire order at my kit.com SL toast
I have a lot of hair so like not a lot
of hair care Brands work for me I love
their satin um line for uh sleep so you
can sleep with like if you get a blowout
the night before the day before you wake
up with the same blowout Not A Rat's
Nest and so again we're getting 30% off
anything and everything at my
kit.com toast that's my
kit.com toast my kit.com toast for 30%
off your order thank you la you're
welcome fa our first story pretty much
always going to be the first story on a
Monday football Sunday was
yesterday headline news Taylor Swift
attended the Chiefs vers Bills game the
Chiefs lost to the bills so Haley
Steinfeld beat out stays winning stays
winning yeah yeah yeah the both the
Chiefs and the Eagles lost yesterday for
the second week in a row which is kind
of shaking Up Chicago the NFL and and
the Eagles lost to the Cowboys so I kind
of sted winning right right but the
Chiefs and Bill's game was really
interesting because like Patrick Mahomes
is crying about their loss because
basically what had happened was towards
the end of the game it was really tight
Patrick threw the ball to Travis Travis
you know got a really good catch and
then before being tackled he tossed it
to another player and that player ran
all the way to the end zone so it was
kind of like this legendary moment for
Travis's career it was an amazing thing
but a flag was thrown down and the catch
did not count the pole play was thrown
out because the guy who he ended up
tossing it to I'm sorry I don't know his
name before the play started when they
were all lined up he was off sides his
foot was over the line so the whole play
was kind of thrown out and the thing is
is it was definitely annoying and Travis
and Andy Reid and everyone and Patrick
Mahomes was so angry like throwing his
helmet everywhere and they ended up
losing the game because of that but at
the end of the day like his toe was off
sides like the rules are the rules and
Travis was just like so mad this is
[__] [__] even so when the game
was over and he went over to shake Josh
Allen's hand he literally like screamed
in Josh Allen's face like my God this is
a [__] call and it's like okay you
lost like it's definitely annoying but
he did that [__] like he broke the rule
not on purpose but like he did his foot
was up the line and like don't be a baby
yeah that's frustrating I have a lot of
thoughts about it like so many thoughts
are running through my head first of all
would you rather like lose in a way
where like you perform so amazing but
it's a frustrating call or like he
[__] up and they lost what's what's
worse
imagine if he didn't catch that ball and
like he had to put it all on himself
that like you know what I mean that's
kind sh I don't like that the thing is
is like one play doesn't make a game
like you had four quarters and you stunk
it up the whole time so now you're going
to blame this one moment like why were
you down why were you down I agree I
agree but like in this moment they were
tied they weren't tied or whatever this
play they down they were down this play
it it came down to this play kind of
yeah but no I I I hear what you're
saying but then my other thought is like
they should have called it when his foot
was over not wait until he scored a
touchdown and that's where I wonder like
if we didn't have all this replay
technology like they would have never
seen the foot and I'm sorry if the ref
doesn't see it on the field like you
missed it I agree by the way like they
should have called it before the ball
was
tossed
yeah so I wonder how that works like
with now with replay technology I guess
the other team could say hey he was off
sides and they go back and rewatch and
yeah he was off sides but I don't know
if you kind of like missed it when it
happened then you can't be angry about
it later no that's true but at the same
time like Patrick Mahomes like being a
baby in the press conference on the
field shaking everyone's hand
like like you did that [__] you know
your team was off sides like so that guy
who had his foot I guess on the one hand
he he [__] up his foot but on the
other hand like he made an amazing play
right they wouldn't have had the play
without the foot kind of cancels each
other out right like what came first the
foot before the play the foot clearly
yeah so Patrick Mahomes is like making
drama cuz he was like being a baby
crying about it in the in the press
conference and on the field and throwing
his helmet and like being a general you
know
Menace and now Taylor has gone to two
games in a row where Travis lost and I
just wonder what that means for their
relationship I feel like it's
strengthening them yeah I agree they're
going through it they're leaning on each
other and he he did good he has nothing
to be ashamed of be ashamed of he can
walk with his head held high even though
he didn't he his head was hung yeah so I
just feel like the two big teams like
are kind of in their flop era two weeks
in a row and I don't know I just don't
don't know what that means for the
league you know for the landscape the
ners one again Niners are killing it
like those are my
unpraised against who the Texans who
aren't like horrible they have a much
better uh what's it called record than
the Jets and we're like getting closer
and closer to what I believe will be a
Christmas time return for Aaron Rogers
he was on the field during the Jets game
like wearing a helmet no not a helmet
like an earpiece like talking to people
right and it's like if the Jets can just
stay in the game till Aaron comes back
like maybe they have a chance no them
winning this game like was kind of major
for maybe Aaron returning and then if
Aaron wins every game like they might be
able to make the playoffs that would be
wonderful they just need to keep playing
like stinkeroo teams yeah but like I
don't know if there are stinkeroo teams
that are more stinkeroo than the Jets
you know but the Jets beat that other
team the Jets have beaten the eagles
which is that's insane the Jets the
Niners and the Cowboys that's kind of
like all of our teams beating the
Eagles so maybe it's not the Eagles as
yet
I don't know I think it like kind of
could be the 49ers year it's like yeah
the Eagles and the ners are like so
famous New Heights Taylor Swift like all
this drama whereas like the 49ers just
are on the other coast keeping their
heads down winning working hard working
hard except I saw something that made me
feel like there's kind of like drama in
the 49ers oh but Christian mcaffry in
the 49ers game the first play of the
game made a got the ball and ran like 90
yards and made it to the one yard line
and then they scored like it was kind of
like a historic legendary play for
Christian's career yeah no they're
they're doing good stuff but I was
watching the game and Brock py you know
how like the quarterback has the thing
on his arm and like tells the team the
play and like they all just kind of
walked away when he was still talking
and I just feel like that's so rude and
just shows like maybe there's not like
that much Harmony it no it shows that
there might be a lack of respect for the
quarterback who's usually like the
leader yeah like he didn't they didn't
break like they just kind of like walked
away from him and he was still talking
and like that if I were Brock like that
would really bother me makes me want to
jump off a cliff more than people
walking away from me as I'm still
talking like oh you hate me I will go I
will see it's an insane thing to do it's
one of the most rude things you could do
to a person and then let alone you know
a whole group doing it right and it's
like I know we're on the football field
but like we could still have manners oh
I got to see this clip because it might
be just a chip like it might be
reflective of dissension within the
community yeah it's just like you know
studying I was just studying the human
behavior and I don't even know I don't
know where I saw the clip I was just
watching like in the background while I
was like making dinner and I saw the TV
and I was like that's rude no you were
looking into the body language we need a
body language expert a B on the toast
don't be [__] rude I would love to
maybe have one of the 49ers explain
themselves for this sort of behavior
what did Brock do yeah no there's why
are they met at Brock yeah why are you
guys like not letting hearing him out
letting him finish speaking maybe he's
like really chatty yeah it's like my God
Brock shut the [__] up we got it we got
the play we'll do it right thanks like
we're running on like a time here like
it's kind of like a timed Affair yeah
maybe called play clock pretty but he
doesn't seem super chatty no he's a man
of God like he only really speaks to God
right if you look at Instagram he's
literally only talking to God that's
beautiful it is beautiful that's
beautiful py L you're
welcome um okay so that's your football
recap tailored and Travis you know going
strong handholding looking cute yeah
they like she didn't make a lot of news
at the game yeah cuz now her presence is
just expected and it's a part of daily
life and it's a beautiful thing yeah are
you ready for our next story yeah the
other big news of the day in some
circles the 2024 Golden Globe
nominations are here I actually don't
think this is the big news of the day in
any circles like for real okay well
there's a couple news making items first
of all the nominees in the big
categories you know people care second
of all there's two new categories that
they've added to the show cinematic and
box office achievement and Motion
Pictures and best oh so Taylor Swift
yeah she was nominated so she is now a
Golden Globe Amy and if she
wins the Golden Globes do not count
towards the egot but it's a nice thing
to have and also best stand-up comedian
on television is a new category okay but
so they have a category for standup
specials was it standup specials they
already had that yeah I saw Amy Schumer
Wanda syes a bunch of people were
nominated but so how is that different
B's best standup comedian on television
so here are the nominees Ricky jves for
his special Armageddon Trevor Noah for
his where I was where was I Chris Rock
for Selective outrage Amy Schumer
emergency contact Sarah Silverman
someone you love and Wanda Sykes I'm an
Entertainer so that's the new category
oh so it's just for specials but they
already had that for limited series
Anthology series or TV movie oh you know
maybe I'm actually getting confused with
the Grammys because the Grammys have uh
for the album comedy album right right
that's a category that makes sense and
then that other category is about box
office achievement so that's about like
you know who broke records at the box
office obviously this year will be
Taylor Swift but I feel like every year
there's been a movie that's question
like Top Gun would have what were the
other nominees for the box office one
let me scroll back down because wouldn't
it be a easy to guess who's going to win
just based on who made the most money
maybe but here are the nominees and then
you'll see why maybe not like
Barbie right cuz it's cinematic and box
office achievement so it's both movie
and money yeah Guardians of the Galaxy
volume 3 John Wick Mission Impossible
Oppenheimer Spider-Man Super Mario Bros
movie t
Swift yeah it's going to be tailored
like no one's talking about like Cinema
and like what it means if it were a
different year and Taylor didn't do what
she did like it probably would have been
Barbie or Oppenheimer because they like
did cool stuff too but it's tailored
because also Barbie and Oppenheimer will
win in other categories and they want
taylored to come to their show yeah yeah
yeah no it's definitely she's winning
yeah so Barbie actually LED nominees
this year with the most nominations so
here are the big categories
let's just do it because technically
it's our job F five like that's what we
do you know we can only like who cares
sound off in the comments do you
care I don't think we're going to have a
lot of people who care but it's it it's
a sign of the times that's what I'll say
best movie picture drama anatomy of a
fall killers of the flower Moon Maestro
which is the Leonard Bernstein it's the
only one I've heard of so far
Oppenheimer past lives the zone of
interest but then don't forget they also
do for Golden globe's best picture
musical or comedy so for the Oscars
these two categories are combined and
the nominees are air American fiction
Barbie the holdovers May December poor
things I saw air and Barbie and I don't
think either one of them should win
because I saw them I've seen not one of
these movies that's so crazy that's so
crazy like air was good but it's
definitely not like a a winner yeah I'm
I'm sure Barbie will win in that
category and I don't know what will be
the
drama dour of the Year me neither the
drama s in
movies so yeah best actress in a
drama I'm moving on we didn't see any of
these I find the TV show ones a little
bit more interesting we can go to TV
shows and that's why the Golden Globes
is nice cuz it is both
yes best drama series 1923 the crown the
Diplomat The Last of Us The Morning Show
succession those are all pretty big The
Last of Us that was the one like with
the zombies Bella Bella Ramsey and Pedro
Pascal yeah yeah yeah okay I feel like
that everyone was talking about that
yeah but like the crown succession it
was its final season oh yeah and also um
Morning Show no what was the first one
1923 yeah 1923 was excellent but I don't
think it's a winner I think it'll be
succession or the last of us this year
best musical or comedy series Abid
Elementary that was weird how I said
that I'm so glad you acknowledged it
like that Elementary but that's how it's
spelled Al Abid Elementary but there is
an a after the T I know I know Let it go
though let it go let the a go Barry the
bear jury duty only murders in the
building Ted last
so competitive yeah competitive I feel
like Ted lasso might win because it's in
its final season but it was the worst
season and it shouldn't win I think
Jerry Duty should win for being a novel
idea and a jolly good show a jolly good
show pure of heart black of hair like
captured the world got people on freey
yeah did you see that that guy Ronald
signed like a development deal with
Amazon Studios like to make more shows
as he should but he should also be
nominated
yeah but it what not really a
performance you know because he didn't
know but he if they were able to get the
nomination for yeah best musical comedy
best limited series this is always the
best category CU limited series are the
best shows all the light we cannot see
oh I didn't realize I see that but isn't
it with
um Mark
Ruffalo no he's not in it no I don't
think so cuz he's the worst I
agree like hot take [__] Mark Ruffalo no
seriously [__] Mark Ruffalo and I I hope
he wasn't in this because he should not
be in any in any sort of Jewish
storytelling no but let me just confirm
even though he is Jewish right is he why
would we think I think he's like one of
those like the worst Jews you know got
it he is in it he is in it he's like a
Seth Rogan but I don't think he's
Jewish Mark
Ruffalo oh I'm seeing a lot of apologies
since 2021 anti-semite of the week Mark
Ruffalo that's funny I don't see
anything where it says he's Jewish oh he
just kind of like has Jewish curly hair
so I assume to no thank God he's not
Jewish we don't need more Jews like that
I agree so all the light we cannot see
back to the limited series nominations
oh like I just that's like the same
thing as like you know Bradley Cooper
doing Maestro and dating Gigi Hadid like
Mark Ruffalo shouldn't be in all the
light we cannot see that's what I'm
saying yeah then beef which also took
kind of the World by storm for a few
days Daisy Jones in the 6th not good
enough in my opinion
Fargo fellow Travelers and lessons in
chemistry oh wow good for realon my
vocals to lessons in chemistry it's just
a darling show that's so well done I
need to watch it I haven't finished it
that would be great for our trip that's
why I saved it I'll watch it again I
don't give a [__] I'll do it I'll do it
I don't give a [__] I'll do it you know
what that's that's another our
references are just out of control are
so Niche does anybody I'm going to tell
you guys what it's from anybody know
what it's from they don't it's from
Borat it's like when Borat like
hitchhikes in this RV full of college
dudes and they like dare it one of the
college dudes to do something and this
guy's so nuts he's like I'll do it I
don't give a [__] I'll do it and we just
he nuts oh face I don't know why we like
quote like it's so Random okay it's on
the list the list is really strong
except there are some things that are
dumb on the list yeah I know we'll have
to why is Beauty and the Beast on the
list we watch that over and over that's
not like a new idea
agreed okay um you want to you care
about the best okay great so that's the
gist congrats to the Noms congrats grads
congrats grads also what I thought was
was interesting is that Timothy shalam
is nominated for Wonka and I feel like
Kylie will go with him this award
season yeah yeah um yeah maybe because
he had his La premiere for the movie
last night and she didn't walk the
carpet but her and Chris snuck in after
the opening credits oh cute yeah so
maybe she didn't want to make that about
her but the Golden Globes like is about
everyone I think we all have a spot I'm
about to ask the dumbest question and I
think it really is emblematic of how
strange Timothy sham is does he play
Charlie or Willie so it's a it's not
Willy Wonka in the Chocolate Factory
it's Wonka it's a Wily Wonka origin
story movie oh so it's about like a
young Jean Wilder a young Wonka right
who was Jee Wilder in that one yeah or
young Johnny Depp right I forgot Johnny
Depp the new one's good
too okay so it's a prequel yeah okay but
would would Timothy shalamay play
Charlie or Willie
he could do both if it was made today
cuz he's like a grown man but also a
toddler he would be
Willie really I think it'd be
Charlie no but he's like 30 Charlie's
like eight so is Timothy sham Hugh
Graham plays in Oompa Loompa yes I saw
him doing press and somebody asked him
you know like why did you take this role
cuz it's definitely out of character and
he was like cuz I needed the money
that's what he's like I need to work
love that for him get his [__] ass up
work no he's like what kind of question
is that like why do you do your job like
I have to do my job but how does he play
nooma Loompa it's like his head is on
like a doll or something cool I would
see
Wonka if I had time that's always a good
story like we could have a lot of fun
with it Hollywood is in its prequel era
you know we've got the Hunger Games
prequel Wonka yeah they just like
squeeze the juice out of anything
remotely good yeah anything remotely
popular yeah but also Hunger Games
prequel is good because it was a book
yeah so that I'm fine with and I'm fine
with Wonka prequel yeah but I'm still
waiting on gastone the movie I'm waiting
on gastone the movie I'm also waiting on
the Twilight prequel movie because there
was a Twilight prequel book right
Midnight
Sun I'm not waiting on the movie because
it's no Robert patson I don't know I do
think they could recapture some of the
magic and like make something really
good you know who could be young Edward
even though by the way Edward will
always look the same it could be Robert
patson no but he's
aging young Edward it's right there it's
right in front of it's right there
Timothy shalam yes yeah yes but I don't
know if I would like it I'm not a
Timothy shalam like girl me neither but
I'm gonna become
one okay she's on a mission
because Kylie loves
him like this is her
man I watched a few episodes of
Kardashians over the weekend like
sporadically and I'm just a Kylie girl
okay you know I know she posted and
deleted her stand with Israel but at
least her reflex was to stand with
Israel was to to fend you know the Mass
Slaughter of Jews it's crazy how the bar
just keeps getting lowered you're
telling me but like at least that was
her reflex to stand with
yeah so I'll take what I can get yeah
are you ready for our next story where I
accidentally clicked on an ad for McAfee
Security but um I'm back to the
story Joe manginello makes a red carpet
debut with Caitlyn oconor following his
split with Sophia varara so it's not
news that Joe manello is in a new
relationship but they did make their red
carpet debut over the weekend the True
Blood star and the winning time actress
oh she's an actress not just a normie
smiled alongside each other Saturday
evening ahead of the children of
Armenian fun Gala at chiani in New York
City in the photos he wraps his arm
around her waist holding her close for
in front of photographers this is just
one of those situations where it's like
really challenging to see other people
living your dream and like you want to
be happy for them but knowing that it
should be you makes it makes that
difficult yeah I love her dress I love
yeah these were cute photos like they
both look so he's so handsome like yeah
I don't know if there's anyone else
who's more
handsome sound off in the comments I
challenge you who is more handsome
seriously than Joe
manella Cara I'm thinking there's a lot
of comps you know like of just like
really handsome men like of course Brad
Pit super handsome honestly I think Joe
manell is way hotter Tom
Hardy handsome not even
close
okay like I'm I'm trying to think of
someone who's more handsome and I don't
know that there is
someone well he's taken tury I'm sorry
to say he's up there with Jason Mamoa
yeah and they have similar Vibes too
yeah yeah like hairy
tall like big manly broad man hot
Lee hot hot I'm happy for him you know I
think T to bounce back after dating
Sophia vargar like the like I think
everyone would agree like this is the
sexiest woman on the planet you know
yeah so it must be hard to find love
after that and I'm so glad he did again
that should be me holding your hand but
I'm happy for them and they've been
dating since September so yeah and now
they're making like a big red red carpet
debut I think this has probably taking
their relationship to the next level
it's nice yeah it is nice we'll keep
tabs on them obviously and Sophia's with
her foot doctor mans so I hope
everyone's happy foctor I forgot about
the foot doctor as long as everybody
like is happy I'm happy I hope you're
happy because I've told Mom I hope
you're happy and I hope your charger is
charging on your iPad cuz it's got used
to your iPad instead of mine you know
the lack kind of were stinking it up
yesterday the what the lack the Los
Angeles
Chargers oh I didn't watch them oh I saw
a couple they were playing um I think
the
the purples um the Ravens I think or the
Viking oh no I saw a man dressed as a
viking in the stands yeah the Viking
whatever team they played got away and
their quarterback's name is Jackson had
amazing plays and the plays like were
really good and I think that purple team
is really good but it was also because
the lack
stunk wow that was a really painful
recap of a football game like no I'm
telling you cuz Zach was like look at
this play he literally made me stand
there and wait for the replay and I was
like yeah but the other team's not doing
their job like so sure this is
impressive but like
Dak yeah yeah
Dak oh my God I can't deal with the Los
Angeles teams because like when it says
lack and law that's all I see I agree
like having a vowel in the middle of
your acronym for your team name is so
unfair like the Jets kind of have it
they're the
nid but so are the Giants they're the
nid too
double nid double nid and then let me
think about other teams well like Dallas
is just Dow on the screen which is fine
Philadelphia Eagles or the fee o that's
not bad because it's like it just feels
like Philly like yeah but it the Nish
the law and the lack I
agree I don't know what
else like the Minnesota I think it says
Min and not like miv
right right
oh my God so hungry it's what are you
gonna have for lunch La treat yourself
something special I'm just kind
of not feeling like I want to nourish my
body you know but you have to take care
of your
body I'm doing Sakara this week how can
I take care of my body when I couldn't
take care of the o oh stop that man
lived Jackie don't worry about me I'm
eating pampered Prince yeah didn't want
for anything before we dive into the
next two stories let me tell you that
they are brought to you by State Farm
the State Farm personal price plan helps
you create an affordable price just for
you the plan is all about being personal
to you and your needs and that means
you're going to get the coverage you
want a policy that helps cover what's
important to you and an affordable price
just for you because after all life is
just better when you can personalize
your experiences so think about it like
this from your go-to coffee orders to
your favorite pair of sweatpants we know
that you love to personalize your entire
day just like we do so you know from
start to finish everything about life is
so personal poetry comedy tacos
breakfast Etc and insurance should be no
different clearly personalization just
makes everything that much better and
state FM believes that insurance should
work the same way your plan your
coverage your selections can all be
personalized by you that's what's so
fabulous cuz let's take Jackie and I for
example we are so similar we finish each
other's sandwiches and even our
insurance needs are so different I mean
you're a homeowner I'm just a lowly
renter you have two cars I'm just slob
with one but you have a a really nice
car you have many
dependents I currently have none so all
that to say my life is sad and my
insurance is reflective of that and
Jackie's life is full and her insurance
is reflective of that as well so like a
good neighbor State Farm is there prices
vary by state options selected by
customer availability and eligibility
may vary like a good neighbor stay Farm
is there hit me like a good neighbor
stay Farm is there
today's episode is also brought to you
by masterclass masterclass makes a very
meaningful gift this season for you and
for anyone on your list because both of
you can learn from the best to become
the best from leadership to effective
communication to cooking whether you're
watching a master class on TV listening
on audio mode in the app or on their
website the quality truly speaks for
itself so true by the way I feel like
there's nothing more personal and like
really Mak somebody feel seen than
gifting them a master class like it's so
nice cuz everybody's interests are so
different and Master Class covers like a
wide range of people so whether your
friend is like really into business your
friend wants to become an actor your
friend has you know is a passion for art
like whatever it is you can you can
really tailor the master class and
master class is always making news like
I've taken so many that I love my
favorite is Chris Jenners because that's
just like for my line of work that's my
beat but I saw they just launched one
with Martha Stewart like how Perfection
is that Perfection no they have classes
for everything it's such a thoughtful
gift and it's also a perfect gift for
this time of year as opposed to like a
birthday or something because it helps
you better yourself in the new year
right right that's so true it's perfect
timing perfect timed gift so thoughtful
remember memberships for masterclass
start at $120 a year for unlimited
access to one-on-one classes with all
180 plus masterclass instructors you can
learn how to negotiate how to negotiate
a raise with Chris Voss manage your
relationships with Esther Perell it'll
boost the confidence of you or the
person that you're gifting it to so this
holiday season give one annual
membership and get one for free at
masterclass.com toast so right now
you'll get two memberships for the price
of one at masterclass.com toast so give
one and then keep one for yourself
masterclass.com toast offer terms apply
today's episode is also brought to you
by Thrive Market our go-to for all of
our grocery and household essentials and
the convenience of getting everything
online and then quickly ship to our
doorstep is a huge timesaver as a Thrive
Market member we save money on every
single grocery order on average we're
saving over 30% every time and on top of
the savings of each order they also have
a deals page that changes daily which
can give you cash back on so many Brands
and they have a price match guad on te I
know with you know all the kids in your
house it's important that you have like
good healthy snacks cleaning supplies
tell me about your experience with
Thrive marqui oh you know I love Thrive
Market I just got a shipment this week
and I got some like new tasty snacks
some pretzel peanut butter bites and I
love that I can get healthy snacks Pizza
PR butter and also like indulge in
snacks that are made with healthy
ingredients so I feel less bad indulging
in my guilty pleasures but I get snacks
for the whole family Puffs things for me
cooking supplies you know I just did my
spice jars but there were a few spices
that I don't have Drive Market has bags
of spices so that are meant to be
putting your jars I don't need to buy
like more jars I can just buy these
refill bags they literally think of
everything and you've got to get on the
th Market grind and the best part the
best part is not having to haul in
groceries from your trunk actually I
think the best part is that when you
join Thrive Market you are also helping
a family in need with their one forone
membership matching program make me look
like an [__] yeah so you join and
thank give Jack join in on the savings
with Thrive Market today and get 30% off
your first order plus a free $60 gift
when you go to thrivemarket.com thee
toast for 30% off your first order plus
that free $60 gift at t r i v market.com
theeast thrivemarket.com
theeast thank you la you're welcome if
you were a football team your acronym
would be
lot yes or my my acronym would be
t t tur oh true T TL TLO t tlu t I like
yeah you've been okay TLO that's like
like if if I was an airport I'd be TLO
no I guess but to me or T
tlu and if you were an airport you'd be
ja no I'd be
Jax oh JX yeah yeah yeah yeah Jack and
Bill yeah I I'm surprised I'm not a
bigger Jaguars fan it's so true your
team and it's my name it's your name
sake I could get some sick merch Jacks
so
true living wrong makes no sense and we
love Jaguars we have a long history with
the Jaguars we love Jaguars we one time
abandoned a jaguar in a parking
lot are you ready for our next story
which is interest interesting but
vague ibv ibv news Okay Bravo stars and
bosses are shaken up after emails about
the network Israel response
leak what yeah so after facing a recent
Revolt from some of its reality stars
Bravo found the latest issue boiling
over behind the scenes was over the
Israel Hamas war page six has learned
but but the Teflon Network as they call
them seems to have averted another
crisis a complic they are the Teflon
Network by the way a complicated Saga
has played out behind the scenes at the
reality Behemoth around its response to
the conflict and the rise of
anti-Semitism in the US page six
understands that shortly after the
October 7th attacks a group of current
and former stars on the Network's raft
of reality TV shows co-signed an email
to a number of senior Bravo figures who
work closely with on air Talent we're
told the signatories appeared to be
satisfied by their response to the
appeal and indeed one of the signatories
told page six that they were more than
satisfied by it but at least one person
party to the email decided to leak the
messages perhaps out of frustration with
the Network's response leading to
considerable anguish among members of
the group as well as some in the Bravo
organization they believed it was a sa
space A source told page six page six
has reviewed the plainly cordial and
respectful messages between the group
and the executives but has decided not
to publish their content to preserve the
privacy of those involved as far as
possible given the extraordinary wa wait
first of all this is so weird that page
six has documents and is saying that
they're not going to release them so if
you're going to write an article about
documents and say you're not going to
release them just scratch scrap the
article yeah so they're letting us know
that something happened behind the
scenes where it seems as though Bravo
Stars you know went to the network to
get support in the wake of October 7th
and rise in anti-Semitism they were
happy with the private response they
received someone was unhappy with it
whether they didn't think it was enough
support or they felt it was like too
much Israel support leaked the documents
to page six page six is letting us know
about the Saga but will not let us know
what was said what yeah this is the
strangest thing I've ever heard yeah
told the email exchange was part of an
ongoing emotionally charge and were told
broadly productive conversation between
Bravo and certain Network stars that had
been going on since very soon after the
attack so it's literally they won't even
say what the people who initially
reached out like what their grievance
was no I I literally this is ibv
interesting but
vague I'm so confused
same but Bravo but my big takeaway I
love that they called them the Teflon
Network when you think about like
historically everything that's happened
on Bravo and like how many scandals
there have been and how many people
there have been on the show off the show
good experience bad experience it's
really crazy that like that like nothing
has happened it's not crazy to me
because I feel like there's no one
person to like ever pin anything on it
used to be Andy but he has extricated
himself over the years he like saw that
being his future and took a step back
and that was actually very smart of him
in terms of preserving his career yeah
like for the bachelor it was Chris
Harrison right and he said I'm not
getting Chris
Harrison
literally also then this article notes
that on Watch What Happens live on the
first night of Hanukkah they lit candles
did you see the clip D and Andy lighting
candles I know that they did but I
didn't see the clip that's cute yeah it
was cute I'm supposed to be like a
message of solidarity usually there's a
manora in the clubhouse but they never
have done like the lighting and the on
it
so Andy's stepping his Jewish [__] up
this year and you know what he's like
one of those Jewish celebrities who has
consistently done the bare minimum maybe
even less but also like marketed and
monetized off of being Jewish masle and
so this you know what he's stepping his
[__] up and he deserves to be applauded
for that so yeah and D was like the
perfect person to have on yes to do it
she one she knew the blessing and she's
an Israeli Jewish Queen yeah agreed she
knew the blessing yeah no I don't he
didn't really but that's okay we can all
learn we can all learn we can all learn
so that's what's going on at Bravo we
don't know that's really weird yeah the
the page ticks having documents and not
releasing them is the most unprecedented
bizarre thing I've ever heard and I
honestly I'm like now really annoyed and
curious and like I want to know yeah I
also kind of like don't want to know you
know cuz I don't want to have to start
hating people yeah I don't want to be
angry at the response and I do hate so
many people and like it's not good for
me like I can't add more when a new
person comes across my desk that I have
to hate like it's frustrating I'm not a
hater is especially when it was a person
like I I might have liked I think I've
had that experience in the last couple
of weeks with Mark Ruffalo no but Mark
ruffalo's been years so but I didn't
know and so I know Mark Ruffalo as 13
Going on 30 as Just Like Heaven you know
a peob and I didn't know he's just a
curly-headed [__] yeah I didn't know
that and I didn't know how many times
he's literally spoken about Israel and
had to release an apology like if every
time you talk about Israel you have to
apologize for being anti-semitic like
look inward [__] no but it's also like
maybe just stop talking about it it's
not like it's part of your job or
required nobody's looking to you so
maybe just stop but you're not a leader
in that in the field so how about just
shut the [__] up what if we all just
shut up unless you have something
interesting and factual to say factual
factual is key key and it's not
negotiable no but for some people it is
right no for me it's not no no s are you
ready for a fifth and final story mhm
because if you're in a relationship
right now I
am you should be careful
today why because today is the most
popular breakup day of the year okay
wait what it's December 11th December
11th I wonder why so T the season for
breakups with splits surging December
11th so much so that has been
unofficially anointed breakup day around
the world the date was determined by
information is beautiful designers who
analyzed Facebook status updates from
2008 finding that Spring Break season is
also breakup season and while most
people haven't changed their
relationship status on Facebook since
2010 experts in more recent data confirm
the weeks leading up to Christmas is
when relationships melt down when
relationship meltdowns heat up the
holidays can bring up a lot of emotions
and challenges for new couples is one
Theory yeah it makes sense that people
would break up around the holiday
because it's like [__] or get off the
pot time am I bringing you home to meet
my family or no also it's like maybe
happens in between Thanksgiving and
Christmas because it's like Thanksgiving
didn't go well we shouldn't be together
it's going to take us two weeks to break
up cuz it's hard to break up I think a
lot of people like think about the idea
like maybe they've been thinking about
this relationship not working out for a
while and then starting the new year
single I think a lot of people think of
it as like a clean slate tabul laasa
yeah so this does make sense but I do
wonder why the 11th in
particular I feel like it's the perfect
difference between Thanksgiving and
Christmas and it's like if you were
thinking about it after
Thanksgiving you had a little time now
you're running out of
time yeah so I hope that if you are in a
happy relationship hope Ben doesn't
break up with me that you make it
through today I do think this is more so
for dating not divorces yeah sound off
in the comments were you broken up with
today or did you do the breaking up let
us know we wish you well if that's the
case yeah and maybe like if you feel
like your relationship is on the rocks
and it it could be your time like just
lay lad today yeah no like they can't
break up with you if they can't find
you
they can't reach you you can't you can't
be single if they literally can't reach
you right but then you'll wind up being
single if you never respond then but
then you ghosted o PL twist
so you've lived long you've lived long
enough to become the villain right but
would you rather break up with someone
or get broken up with that's a really
good question and I've never done either
so I'm
just speaking in
hypothetic honestly I think making the
decision is pro if if you're like a good
person and you care about this person
you're not just like a dick who breaks
up with someone but if you're like if
you're if you loved this person and I
think making the decision is probably
really hard I think I would prefer to
have the decision be made for me except
then I have to tell people I got dumped
which is like embarrassing for sure no I
think getting broken up with is so much
better cuz then you also don't have
regrets like should I have done it
should Choice having something happen to
you versus you having to choose I mean
not to make everything about me but
that's literally how I felt with Theo
like I kept say saying like I wish he
would just you know leave us on his own
accord and I didn't have to make this
decision and you know HP pull the
metaphorical plug if you will yes no
it's the exact same thing if it had just
happened making hard decisions sucks
yeah and if you're like a person and I'm
talking about like the type of person
who would break up with someone that
they loved and cared about but just
didn't think it was the right decision
and like wanted to do it in a nice
meaningful way not someone who's just
like a dick and is like I don't like you
bye right right right but I think also
what's really hard is even if you know
it's the right decision in the moment
you make that decision but say you don't
meet someone for a year did I make the
right decision 2 years 5 years always
have regret as opposed to the other
person who was like well they broke up
with me there was nothing I could do
they don't live in regret like that
right no making decisions is hard yeah
but it's important to do so it is it is
but it's easier when someone makes it
for you if it can be done so yeah
although I would hate like having to
tell people I got dumped I do think I
would prefer to be dumped me too so
maybe pick up the phone today yeah maybe
take action take take control of your
life and if you find yourself single
today you're going to be fine it gets
better you're going to be fine you're
going to be great better was meant to be
those were the Fast Five and they
weren't great especially if they would
be so cliche as to break up with you on
the day that everyone's doing it it's
like you don't even have an original
thought you're just a static so true
like be creative no you're just a
statistic yeah why would I want to be
with you
stat yeah start calling them that okay
stat whatever you
say what do you want stat what do you
want
stat that's our show those were our
stories and I can I know you didn't love
them I feel proud of them I can go on
with my head held high you can you know
be happy with who you are when you lay
your pillow down on when you lay your
head on your pillow at night you can
live with that at least today
at check in
tomorrow that's our show you guys thank
you so much for listening to the toast
Millenia Morning Show where we deliver
the fast life story so you need to know
every Monday through Friday on YouTube
so you're watching us on YouTube please
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also
podcasting have a great day guys happy
Monday we love you we'll see you
tomorrow love you
bye